[موسيقى]
طبعا الطفوله احلى مرحله يمر بها الانسان
تكون خاليه من المسؤوليات والاولويات
اني طفولتي انتهت بعمر 13 سنه بيومه اللي
تزوجت بيه فجاه اتحولت من طفله اكبر
همومها واجباتها المدرسيه الى امراه عندها
مسؤوليات واولويات تخص البيت والزوج
ومسؤوليات الحياه الكثيره
طبعا الشيء طبيعي انه بهاي المرحله
كانسانه حتكون الالم والتعب والجهد يكون
يمكن اكثر من طاقه الانسان بس اني كانت
اولويتي وكانت اكبر اهتمامي انه اني اصنع
عائله مثاليه ايش تتوقعون من طفله مراهقه
ام الاربعه اطفال تتمنى تنجح بحياتها ترسم
طريق ناجح لها تخطي خطى مستقبل تثبت
بذاتها وترضي بي نفسها
مكان قدامي غير الخياطه اللي اني بعمر 13
العفو بعمر الخمس سنوات اني تعلمتها من
امي كنت ايدها اليمين بهذا الوقت انه
اساعدها فهذه اتخذتها اني تقنتها على
مستوى الفساتين وبدلات الاعراس
شلون احس بقيمتي بهذه الحياه شلون احس انه
اني مو مجرد رقم بهذا العالم
لازم اثبت لنفسي انه اني اقدر خصوصي انه
اني احس نفسي انه انا عندي امكانيه وعندي
عندي امكانيه للعمل الحرفي انه انا ممكن
اقدر اشتغل اي شيء ممكن اشوفك
طبعا بهذا الوقت اني ام الاربعه اطفال
وزوجه واشتغل خياطه بالاضافه الى انه زوجي
كان عنده مطعم اني كنت اساعده بتجهيز
المقبلات واجهز القص هذا الشاورما اني
اشدها بالشيش
كنت شايله عن زوجي مسؤوليه يمكن جزء من
مسؤوليته بالمطعم وبمصاريف المطعم ايضا
هنانا شلون اني ابدي شلون راح ارسم
مستقبلي شلون اني راح اكون بموقف انه اني
راضيه بيه على نفسي هو الشيء طبيعي انه
انا ما عندي غير الخياطه وبنفس الوقت اني
ما عندي شهاده ممكن تساعدني ممكن تخليني
ارتدي مشواري
فالخياطه كانت هي طريقي
بهذا الوقت اني باوعت على بيتنا اني كلش
بيتوتيه كلش احب البيت احب كل تفاصيله
مهما كانت بسيطه او قديمه او كل تفاصيله
فهنانه بيتنا كان كلش قديم كلش بيه تفاصيل
انا كنت ما حبتها فهناك كان لازم اني
اشتغله زين شلون اشتغل اني داخله كلش
محدود شلون راح اقدر
اطلع النتيجه اللي اني تقنعني او الاني
ترضيني فهنانه كان لازم انه قرار انه اني
اشتغله بايدي شنو يحتاج البيت يحتاج صبه
يحتاج صبغ للجدران يحتاج اثبت مغسله بفلان
مكان اي شيء يحتاجه البيت كنت اني اشتغله
طبعا هو الموضوع مو سهل ومو حكي لسان شلون
هسه اخذ من عندي وقت يمكن اشهر اي شيء كان
يحتاجه مثلا احتاج ميزه التلفزيون كنت اني
اصنعه هاي طبعا قبل وبعد
اني اصنعه محتاجه قطعه قديمه هي شكلها ما
حلو ما عاجبني اني كنت اغير بشكلها
بالمكان اللي احتاجه
مرور الوقت ويا كل قطعه اصنعها او كل كل
عمل انتجه اني كان هذا يساعدني ويعطيني
القوه
وثقه بنفسي اكثر
يمكن النتيجه ما كانت
مبهره لدرجه انه تبهر كل اللي يشوفونه بس
اني النتيجه البيت من كملته وبنفس الوقت
اني صانعته بايدي يمكن اني من الناس اللي
كلش احب الاشياء اللي تنصنع باليد احس
انها قيمه كلش كبيره عندنا حتى بعد مرور
سنوات
طبعا بهذا الوقت اني من الناس اللي كلش
يؤمنون انه الاحلام ما تموت انه اني مهما
عشت ومهما عانيت انه اني احلامي لازم
احققها فبهذا الوقت اني بسنه 2018 قررت
انه امتحن خارجي بس اني ما توفقت لانه
كانت عندي ظروف كلش هوايه طبعا هو المفروض
انه الاحلام احنا نحبها وما نتنازل عنها
بس بنفس الوقت انه احنا نسعى لها قرارنا
بداخلنا ان احنا نسعى الاحلامنا وان احنا
نشتغل عليها ونجتهد عليها لانه الاحلام
تبقى خيال بدون السعي الحقيقي للوصول الها
طبعا من هنا احنا كعائله كنا مقررين نستقر
خارج العراق بهذا الوقت اني طبعا اني من
مجتمع كلش محافظ كلش عشائري انه ما يعطي
مساحه كافيه للبنت ما راح تقدر تتحرك او
تعمل انه انا ما عندي شهاده ما راح اقدر
اشتغل بالعمل الحري اللي انا اشوف نفسي
بيه واللي راح القى نفسي بيه فاحنا هنا
كعالم مقررين نستقر خارج العراق فاني هنا
كنت موافقه كل شي بحياتي كل شي كل عمل
اشتغل بهذا الوقت اني مجرد انه اعبر بيه
ايام انتظر الوقت اللي اسافر بيه انه
بلد ثانيه اني راح اقدر اخذ المساحه اللي
احتاجها في سبيل انه ابدي
عملي اني بالدرجه الاولى اني خياطه كلش
بيرفكت بالفساتين وبالبدلات فكان ببالي
انه افتح مشروع يخص دار الازياء والفاشون
والملابس كنت متاكده انه اني راح انجح
بيها نجاح ظاهر
اني راح افتح شي يخص الصناعه شي يخص هنانا
مهنتي يعني اني كلش اشتاقناتهم بس كصناعه
هي هوايه الي شي اني احبه كلش حابه
ادع بيه او بس هو على مستوى البيت على
مستوى البيت انه الاشياء البسيطه اللي
احتاجها وهي بالاخير هي هوايتي
الغريب بالامر انه اني هذي كانت مجرد فكره
خاليه من اي تفاصيل مجرد انه اني احب اصنع
مجرد انه انا احب
اصنع اشياء بايدي بعدها كلش بسيطه كانت
عندي مجرد منشار تخريم مجرد دريل مفك
بالنسبه الي كهاويه تشتغل بس خشب مكان اكو
فرق بين المقص والمنشار بالنسبه اليها حتى
يعني القماش وبين الخشب بين الالمنيوم
بالنسبه اليك كفصال كهندسه انا ما اشوف
بيناتهم ذاك الفرق الكبير اللي اقدر انتجه
من القماش راح بنفس الوقت اقدر انتجه
بقطعه الخشب هنا بالقماش اقدر اخيط كفر
للانسان هنانه بقطعه الخشب اقدر اصنع قطعه
يستخدمها الانسان هي بالنتيجه اني بمخيلتي
هي كلها هندسه انا بسبب الخياطه انه انا
عندي هندسه كلش قويه
كانوا اي شيء يحتاجوه اقاربنا من
من تاسيس كهرباء من تثبيت بيدريل من باقي
تفاصيل المنزل شنو يحتاج لبيتهم اني ممكن
اشتغله الهم فمرور الوقت صار هذا الشيء
كلش دافع قوي لي كل شيء عزيزي ثقتي بنفسي
كلش اشوف نفسي انه اني
نجاحي حيكون كلش قوي انه اني ما ممكن
اتردد انه انا راح ادخل مجال انه اني
واثقه بنفسي حانجح بيه
طبعا
من عجائب القدر انه وقت السفر كلش قرب صار
يمكن اياه باقي له ايام معدوده لكن صار شي
كلش مو بالحسبان انه كورونا انسدت مطارات
العالم كليتها حتى اشعار اخر يمكن لوهله
انه انا حسيت احلامي ممكن صعب تتحقق شلون
راح اقدر راح اقدر انجح بعمل حر بالعراق
بالمسؤوليات وبالالتزامات بتقييد المجتمع
بتعاملي مع العمال وتعاملي مع الزبائن مهن
اني ما عندي خلفيات الها قويه ممكن الناس
تتقبلها علي
لحد ما جاء اليوم اشتغلت غرفه نوم جارتي
وهي صديقتي طلبت مني اشتغل
بهذا الوقت اني بالنسبه الي كانت النتيجه
اكثر من تمام كلش قنعتني هنانه كل طاقتي
بكل حب بكل عزيمه بدون اي تردد قررت انه
ادخل مجال النجاره
يمكن كانت كبداايتي كانت الفكره اللي
ببالي انه نعم بعدني انا ممكن خارج العراق
انجح بها بس هسه مجرد انه اقوي نفسي بيها
مجرد انه استمر بيها لانه انا هنا بعدني
واثقه اني ما راح اقدر انجح داخل العراق
من قصص النجاح بالنسبه الي انه اني اول
شيء اول شيء حبيت اشتريه للورشه مالتي
اللي اني قررت انه اشتغل داخل البيت ما
راح اطلع من البيت الورشه مالتي داخل
البيت
دا يشتركون فتت بشارع هذا الشارع بالنسبه
الي حسيته عالمي حسيته كانه ماده امشي
بدزني الان كل التفاصيل اللي احبها اني من
العدد ومن الادوات من
الاكسسوارات من الاشياء يمكن اذا نشوفها
بقطعه نقول هاي شلون هاي شلون صارت هاي
شركه يلا تقدر تصنعها يمكن من نشوف رجل
المالك الميز مال تلفزيون بتفاصيلها
وهندستها وشلون مركبيها نقول هاي احنا مو
احنا اللي نصنعها هذه شركات خاصه هي ممكن
اللي تصنعها بس اني من فتت بهذا الشارع
شفت العالم اللي انا اتخيله واللي اني كلش
احبه لقيته بهذا الشارع من من صدمتي بيه
ومن انبهاري من هذا الشارع بس اني ما اعرف
شلون ارجع له ما اعرف شنو اسمه ما اعرف
شلون شنو راح اسال وراح ارجع له كملت
طريقي اشتريت الكمبريسر رجعت للبيت اني
الشارع بالليل هو بقى صورته كلياتها ببالي
من
شارع ببالي ثاني يوم اخر نقطه انه اني
انزلها لهذا الشارع رحت فده اسال اي واحد
يفوت اهل السيارات اهل التكاسي شارع بيه
كذا معمل كذا قطع بره كذا معرض كذا تفاصيل
البعض عرفوه دلوني بيه وهو قطر الندى وهو
طبعا الشارع اللي لحد الان انا عنده من
عنده
من من دخلت بيه دا اشوف ابو الاكسسوار ابو
الانشائيه ابو الاسفنج ابو الخشب ها هي
حسيت نفسي انه اني تمام يعني اني عندي ثقه
بنفسي عندي ثقه بامكانيتي عندي المكان
اللي اعرف منين اجيب الاشياء اللي احتاجها
انا هنانا كلش كلش وثقت بخطوتي كلش حسيت
انه هي الخطوه الاولى طريق نجاحي طبعا من
العقبات ومن الصعوبات اللي واجهتني هي
اكثر عقبه واجهتني بدايه شغلي انه اني ما
يقارب السنتين اني وريشتي داخل البيت طبعا
هو البيت مسكن هو للراحه اني هذا المسكن
اللي هو اللي راحتي وراحت عائلتي اني هذا
مستخدمته كورشه بالبدايه اخذت الكراج ثاني
شيء رجعت للحديقه ثالث شيء اخذت
الاستقبال فرغتها من الغرض اخر شيء اخذت
الكراج اللي قدام الباب داخلي بها الطلبات
والاوردرات اللي تجيني من الزب
هذه كانت نقطه كلش كلش صعبه من النقاط
اللي يواجهتها بس الحمد لله انه اني بهذا
المكان قدرت اطلع قطع كلش
كانت اكثر اكثر من مرضيه الزبائن ايضا من
العقبات اللي واجهتني خلال هاي السنتين
يمكن اذا تسالون اين الجار او اي دوشه انه
هذا الشيء كله صعب انه احنا ما راح نقدر
نسوي انه انا ما يقارب السنتين اني فصالي
للقماش اللي هو
اني افصله على الارض طبعا هذا الشيء كلش
كلش صعب بنفس الوقت انه انا حتى ميزه اللي
احنا نسميه تسقاه اللي نفصل عليه وكذا هو
يا اما افصل على الارض هنانا الخشب واللي
احتاجها مرات هو الميز مالتي اللي هو
المنشار نفسه منشار التشريح اني استخدمه
كل التفاصيل بحكم انه انا ما راح ما قدرت
اوفر كل العدد وكل الادوات اللي احتاجها
ويمكن هي العدد اللي كانت عندي وهي لحد
الان هي نفسها عندي انه هي يا دوب يمكن
تكيفي هاوي بس اني اذا اطلع منها القطعه
الحمد لله انه هي كلش ممتازه وكلش بيرفكت
وكلش ترضيني واذا ترضي كل احد يشوفها
الزبائن
[تصفيق]
طبعا انتبهت نجاح بشغلي وسبتت امكانيتي
وصارت صارت كمهنه رئيسيه الي انه اني
معتمده عليها بداخلي
ملتزمه بيها وملتزمه بطلبات وملتزمه
باوردرات هنانا حلمي لازم يتحقق انه وايد
تكون عندي شهاده فقدمت للثالث متوسط عن
طريق الخارجي طبعا هي ما كان فد خطوه كانت
كلش سهله في ظل الالتزامات في ظل الطلبات
في ظل في ظل العائله وفي ظل الاطفال طبعا
كانت خطوه كلش صعبه اخذت وقت واخذت جهد
كلش كبير بس الحمد لله هذه المره قدرت
انجح بها وقدرت اثبت نفسي بها
[تصفيق]
بعد هذه هذه كليتها انه انا صارت عندي
طلبات صارت تجيني عن طريق حساباتي على
الانستجرام والتيك توك فهنانه صار انه
المساحه اللي عندي صارت انه لازم افتح
معمل فالحمد لله يمكن يمكن ما كان المعمل
بالنتيجه او بالصوره اللي انا اتخيلها ولا
بالصوره اللي اني اتمناها بس بحكم
امكانيتي بحكم وضعي كنت فتحت معمل انه
كشكل مبدئي كان كلش مرضى اليه لحتى استنوا
طلبات عدد اكثر من طلبات الزبائن واقدر
اشغل كادر وياية والحمد لله حاليا انا
اشتغل بالمعمل وهو يمكن اول معمل عراقي
ايادي امراه يخص النجاره
طبعا يمكن اكثر نقطه هي تلفت انتباهي بكل
يصير من اشوف الفخر بعيون اطفالي من اشوف
فخرهم بي واشوف حبهم واعتزازهم بيه هذا
الشيء طبعا هذا هو ثمره تعبي وثمره صبري
وثمره نجاحي
طبعا يمكن من محاسن الصدف نعاني اني اني
طبعا طبيعه الحال انه انا كلش بعيده على
السوشيال ميديا
وقتي بحكم كان شغلي والتزاماتي كان كلش
قليل على مواقع التواصل بالصدفه مره اتفرج
على لقاء للبشير والشيخ شاهين انه يدعمون
صناع المحتوى هنانا قررت اني انه افتح
محتوى انه مهنتي هي نفسها تكون فيديوهات
قصيره بمحتوى على مواقع التواصل على
انستجرام على يوتيوب على تيك توك
لانه اني من مجتمع كلش محافظ اني عانيت من
هذه النقطه عانيت كلش هوايه يلا وصلت لهذه
النقطه
كنت بالسابق اتمنى انه تكون عندي عصا
سحريه او اتمنى تكون عندي فطاقه او سلطه
انه اغير بيها العادات او اغير بها
التقاليد او اغير هذه
النظره النمطيه للبنت انه انت بنت انه انت
ما راح تقدرين تنجحين ما راح تقدرين
تستمرين يمكن هذه المهنه صعبه عليك وهذه
المهنه صعبه عليك لا اني امراه واني انثى
واني اشتغل بالمجال اللي اشوف نفسي به صح
ما دام اني ما مرتكبه شيء غلط واني ما
ماذي احد وانا هذا طريقي اللي اقدر اشوف
نفسي انجح بيه ممكن اني افيد نفسي وافيد
مجتمعي بنفس الوقت
[تصفيق]
كان يمكن المحتوى كان هو الوسيله او
الاداه اللي انا اقدر اساعد بيها او يمكن
اوصل بها مجرد رساله انه نغير صوره
المجتمع نغير صوره اللي دا ياخذها على
البنات او حتى الاهل ممكن انه من يشوفون
بنيه ناجحه بمجالها
من خلال المحتوى انه احنا راح نتغير انه
احنا ممكن تصير عندنا نظره اكبر او نظره
انه احنا نقدر نساعد بيها بناتنا ونقدم
لهم الطاقه والدعم اللي هم يحتاجوا لحتى
ينجحون بحياتهم
يمكن هسا واضحه عندكم انه هذه هي نهايه
قصتي انه اني حققت وتعبت ووصلت للي اريده
لا طبعا هي هذي بدايه الخطوه بدايه بدايه
قصتي اني حاليا
اني ان شاء الله للمستقبل القريب اقدر
افتح ورشات تاهيليه تاهل البنات لهكذا انه
انت بنيه راح تقدرين تنجحين فاقدر اساعدها
ممكن انه تنجح بمجال النجاره او الدوشمه
او الصبغ وباقي تفاصيل هذه المهن اللي
احنا هي هي مو احتكار وانما هي صارت مختصه
بالرجال
اخر شيء احب اقول لكم اياه لا تتنازلين عن
حلمك ولا تتنازلي على حلمك ولا تتنازل عن
حلمك حلمك هو حياتك هو هدفك للمستقبل يمكن
يمكن اني نجاره يمكن البعض يشوف يقول هو
يعني هي ما مصنعه شي غريب بس اني هذا حلمي
هذا تعبي السنيني وتعب حياتي يمكن قدرت
اترجمه وقدرت اثبته فانتي ايضا لا تتنازلي
عن حلمك ولا تتنازل عن حلمك حلمك واهدافك
هي اللي راح تصنع منك من حضرتك وتصنع من
مستقبلك وتصنعك المجتمعك
[موسيقى]